hi everyone happy Wednesday
um a couple of course reminders uh
homework three is due tonight uh
optional homework four is out today
um and also hopefully you've been
getting started on your projects the
project Milestone is due in two weeks on
Wednesday
again we're similar to the proposals
we're going to be grading them pretty
lightly really the goal is to be able to
give you feedback on your project and
yeah help you keep on track in terms of
making progress towards the uh towards
the end
um so for today we're going to recap uh
quickly Monday's lecture on the basics
of meta RL then we're going to talk a
lot about learning how to explore
this will be
um first just talking about end-to-end
optimization of exploration strategies
and then talking about some alternative
strategies that address some of the
shortcomings of end-to-end optimization
and then talking about an approach that
tries to get kind of the best of both
worlds
um metal RL and learning to explore is
the focus of homework for and so this
lecture will be probably super useful
for that homework
and then the goals of the lecture are to
understand the challenges of end-to-end
optimization of exploration
uh understand the basics of using some
alternative strategies and then also be
able to understand and implement the
last approach that decouples exploration
and exploitation
cool
so to recap meta RL and what we talked
about last time
um we want to be able to
learn how to solve a maze for example or
solve a new task quickly and the way
that we do this is we learn how to learn
many different mazes or many different
meta training tasks and then use this to
try to quickly solve a new task where we
explore in a new maze this exploration
constitutes our training data set and
then we use this to solve a task and
acquire a policy that can go straight to
the goal of the maze
we also talked about the problem of meta
RL kind of more abstractly where we want
to be able to
take some experience in a task and use
that to form a policy that maps from
states to actions that can maximize
reward for that given task
and the way that we do this is we
collect a data set of data sets one data
set for each task or one replay buffer
for each task and we use this to learn
how to quickly solve one of the tasks in
our task distribution so that we can
hopefully generalize to a new task
and so there are two aspects of the meta
RL problem one is picking a a good
function f that can learn how to adapt
from data
and the other is figuring out how to
actually go about collecting and
exploring in the task
um and the second part is essentially
the problem of learning how to explore
and this is exactly what we'll be
focusing on in this lecture
um we sort of swept this under the rug
on Monday and there are actually
circumstances where exploration is quite
non-trivial and you want to learn a more
sophisticated exploration strategy then
um where you're actually optimizing for
the exploration strategy rather than
something more arbitrary
cool and then in today's lecture we're
going to be focusing on Black Box meta
RL methods last time we also talked
about optimization based meta RL but
here we're really going to be focusing
on Black Box methods
um and the way that we saw Black Box
methods working is you have for example
of our current neural network that takes
us and put the experience so far and
uses that to infer what a good action is
for solving the task and you can think
of D train as essentially all of your
experience up until the current time
step and your query set as the current
time step and you're going to be
optimizing this network for many
different uh many different sizes of
support sets
for the purpose of this lecture we're
going to call our initial episodes
exploration episodes and our later
episodes execution episodes
um they don't necessarily need to have a
very hard breakdown of like one episode
for exploration and one episode for
execution
but um it'll be helpful just in terms of
understanding uh it'll be helpful to
kind of break these into two different
parts of the problem for understanding
some of the challenges that come up when
you learn how to explore
also sometimes in the exploration
episode
um sometimes you actually don't really
care about how like the reward that the
policy is achieving during the
exploration episode oftentimes you only
care about that during the execution
episode although in some circumstances
you might also want your exploration
episode not to like jump off a cliff for
example
um in terms of Black Box approaches
they're very general and expressive
there's a variety of design choices in
the architecture but they can be
difficult to optimize like we talked a
little bit about on Monday
we also talked about how these methods
will inherit the sample efficiency of
their outer RL optimizer
um so that's a recap of
some of the concepts that we covered on
Monday
now we're going to be talking about
learning how to explore
and I'd like to start this by taking a
step back and thinking about
reinforcement learning in general
and
oftentimes in reinforcement learning
we'll use an exploration a number of
different exploration strategies maybe
we will try to maximize the entropy of
our policy and do more random things
there's also exploration strategies
known as Epsilon greedy where with some
probability you take a random action and
with um
with the rest of your probability you
take an action according to your policy
um and these exploration strategies are
very naive
and we're actually using the same
exploration strategies for solving a
wide range of problems
and if we take a step back it seems a
little bit silly to be thinking about
using the same exploration approach for
learning to navigate an environment
as and the same exploration approach for
making recommendations to users for
learning a policy for compute computer
system caching or physically operating a
robot
and essentially in reinforcement
learning the way that we approach
exploration is we have a single strategy
like Epsilon greedy and we apply that to
all these kinds of problems
um and that seems a little bit silly
because uh you would expect that in a
lot of these different applications you
want strategies that are kind of
targeting aspects of that problem
so for example in navigation we want
exploration strategies that try to reach
different parts of the environment
in um in recommender systems we may want
to kind of have approaches that are
targeted towards particular users and
treat different users differently
in terms of physically operating a tool
or a machine there are probably certain
things that we want to try and certain
things that are irrelevant and won't be
helpful like walking to another room
probably won't be helpful in terms of
exploration for that particular tool or
machine
and so in some ways the idea behind
meta reinforcement learning is trying to
learn exploration strategies based on
other tasks in that particular domain
enabled in order to be able to
much more targeted in order to explore
in a much more targeted way for a
particular domain
um yeah and so if these algorithms are
very effective we may be able to get
exploration strategies that are very
targeted and that are some more domain
specific than things like Epsilon greedy
foreign
so
in terms of the algorithms that we'll
think about
um I want to think about them in the
context of an example and I think that
this should help give across some of the
intuition behind the algorithms
and the example that we'll consider is
as follows so we have some agent uh
this is uh was choosing to take actions
in the environment
and there are a number of different
hallways in the environment
and different tasks correspond to
navigating to the end of one of the
hallways and receiving a reward at the
end of the hallway
um and so for one task maybe the goal is
to go to the end of hallway two and
collect a reward for another task the
goal is to go to Hallway K and collect
the reward and so forth
um so this is kind of the basic version
version of the setup and if you were to
learn how to explore you would imagine
that you might want to kind of explore
the ends of different hallways
we're going to add one more bit to this
environment which is that on the ground
there's also some paper that has
instructions on a hallway that is
um on simply where the robot should go
for the current task
cool
um and so uh this is also kind of
Illustrated in a much more basic way
right here as well
um does anyone have thoughts on what
some strategies are for exploring and
learning a new task
yep
yeah so one thing that you could do is
you could try to find the sheet of paper
on the ground read it use that to figure
out where to go and then if you can
effectively read what's on the paper
then you could just go there directly
and then another strategy would be if
you don't know how to read you could try
to basically just go down all of the
hallways until you find the hallway that
gives you reward
um so these are two effective strategies
um and those are I think the only two
effective strategies for solving this
problem
um
if you don't learn to go to the end of
the hallways or you don't learn how to
read then you probably won't be able to
learn the task
okay so we'll be considering this
example throughout and it'll be useful
for understanding different approaches
so now the first approach for learning
how to explore is just to try to
optimize for exploration and
task execution end to end with respect
to the reward of solving the task
um this is essentially what we saw in
the lecture on Monday
where we train a big recurrent neural
network to be able to do both
exploration and execution for the task
and we could train it with something
like key learning or something like
policy gradients if you train it like
policy with policy gradients we'll get
an objective that looks something like
this
and um essentially what this is going to
be trying to doing is uh your your
policy is going to need to both explore
as well as use the exploration data in
order to solve the task
and so if we think about the meta
training process
um it's going to be collecting episodes
and trying to learn how to explore and
solve tasks
and so say during meta training
um
maybe it collects a
uh it's trying to learn how to explore
and solve the task distribution maybe it
collects um a trajectory that that looks
like this that goes to
the maybe even the correct hallway and
gets a reward
an episode that looks like this
um is great in the sense that it's going
to get positive reward for the current
task
but it's not actually going to be able
to learn exploration from this
trajectory
because it hasn't D train
isn't really going to say anything about
what what task like is or isn't the case
until it gets to the very end
um and so
as a result even though it's giving some
positive reward for the task
it's going to be fairly difficult to use
a trajectory like this to figure out how
to both explore and solve the task
now another trajectory that we might
consider is maybe something like this
where the agent kind of goes to one the
end of one hallway and then goes to this
one
this trajectory will
um it will get positive reward again and
it's actually also going to get positive
reward for
um
positive it's going to get positive
reward that will help it learn an
exploration strategy of going to
different hallways and so in general
this is this directory will probably be
much more helpful than the green
trajectory because they can learn an
exploration strategy which is to
if you see a negative reward then you
should go to a different hallway so this
will be helpful
although
it's going to be helpful for learning a
sub-optimal strategy because uh the
optimal strategy would be to read the
instructions first and then go to the
correct hallway
and then lastly say that you have a
trajectory that looks like this where
the agent actually does go and reads the
instructions
um and then maybe after it reads the
instructions it does some random stuff
an episode like this
is good in the sense that it is actually
showing some exploratory Behavior that's
informative for the task
however it's not going to be able to use
this experience in a meaningful way
because it's still going to get a reward
of zero for this experience
and so in this last case
um
it has good exploratory Behavior but
that is not going to get any reward for
this exploratory Behavior
and as a result the only kind of in
terms of learning the optimal strategy
the only kinds of trajectories that will
be helpful for learning is if it
actually
um kind of first goes to the
instructions and then goes to the
correct
uh hallway
and so this illustrates kind of the
challenge of learning exploration and
exploitation end to end
which is that if you're trying to learn
both of them at the same time you really
need trajectories that do both
exploration and execution of the task
in order to get good signal for how to
do exploration and execution together
and if you have a trajectory that does
only one of them that isn't going to
help you very well to essentially learn
um learn how to solve tasks in your task
distribution
any questions about this
yeah the question is um can you just
reward the agent for like looking at the
instructions regardless of what it does
after that
um and that's something that you can
definitely do if you know what a good
exploration strategy is then you could
essentially change the rewards during
meta training to encourage it to kind of
shape its exploration behavior and that
will encourage it that will make the
problem much easier and that will
encourage it to
um
to actually do that behavior note that
you do need to have some sort of domain
specific information in order to do that
you need to know what a good exploration
strategy is in order to provide that
kind of reward shaping
um
if you can do that then that will help
solve the problem if you don't know that
information then you're still kind of
stuck with um
with uh the challenge of this sort of
end-to-end optimization
cool so
um
to summarize kind of this sort of
end-to-end approach it's very simple and
in principle will lead to the optimal
strategy if you give it enough data and
it eventually kind of explores the
correct exploration and execution
strategy
the downside is that um it's a very
challenging optimization process
especially when exploration is difficult
because it needs to kind of figure out
that exploration strategy in conjunction
with solving the task
um we can also look at another example
of a kind of a hard exploration meta RL
problem
and we can see how this problem arises
in that problem as well so say that we
want our robot to be able to cook us a
meal which would be nice
and the Mediterranean tasks correspond
to cooking in a number of previous
kitchens
and then our goal is for the robot to be
able to cook us a meal in our kitchen
which is a new kitchen
in order to
cook you need to find ingredients for
the meal and then you also need to use
those ingredients to make the meal
and so you can think of exploration as
finding the ingredients and execution is
actually using those ingredients to cook
and one of the things that's difficult
about end-to-end optimization is you
have a kind of a chicken and egg problem
between learning how to explore and
learning how to solve the task
um and if you uh
say for example you haven't yet learned
how to explore you don't know how to
find ingredients
then if you don't have ingredients then
you can't learn how to cook
and likewise if you haven't yet learned
how to cook
then you're not going to get any reward
for finding the ingredients
this is the second example is just like
this case where if you haven't yet
learned how to read instructions and go
to the correct goal then you're not
going to get any reward for looking at
the instructions
and so essentially you have this
coupling problem where learning how to
explore and learning how to solve tasks
depend on one another
and if you try to optimize for these end
to end this can lead to poor local
Optimum like the approach of exploring
different hallways
it can also lead to very poor sample
efficiency because you need a lot more
data in order to happen upon the
strategy that explores and solves the
task
cool
um so that's that's the gist of why
end-to-end training is hard
um kind of in the rest of this lecture
we'll talk about alternative strategies
that uh essentially try to
bypass the difficulty of this end-to-end
optimization
um do folks understand why end-to-end
optimization is hard
cool I see nods okay
so
the second solution that we're looking
at that we will look at is to try to
leverage alternative exploration
strategies
um and instead of trying to explicitly
learn an exploration strategy that is
kind of the best approach for
um for trying to figure out what the
task is we're going to leverage
alternative strategies that might help
us figure out what the task is they
might be some optimal strategies but
they're going to be easier to use and
optimize for than the end-to-end
approach
cool um so the first thing that we'll
consider is to use posterior sampling
which is also known as Thompson sampling
and at a high level the way that this is
going to work
is
I'll erase kind of bees here the way
this is going to work is we're going to
learn how to solve each of the tasks
so we'll learn how to navigate to the
end of hallways
and then we're going to maintain a
belief about what we think the task is
and sample from kind of our belief or
sample from our distribution of what we
think the task is
and so what we can do is we can say that
we have learned that the task correspond
to going to different hallways
then we will start by kind of having a
fairly uniform
prior over tasks we'll sample from this
to kind of pick a particular task that
we might want to do so maybe we'll
sample uh task 2 to start
then we will execute our policy for that
task which will go to there we'll then
see that we get uh we don't get a
positive reward from this
then we will
update our kind of belief over the task
given the experience that we've seen so
far
we'll sample a new task from our updated
belief this new distribution is going to
be everything but this task right here
and
um
well then again execute kind of pick a
different task and execute for that so
maybe we'll sample this task
and then we will get a positive reward
here
well then kind of again update our
belief over
um the task given
the experience we have so far and once
we see a positive reward here our
distribution over what we think the task
is is going to be much narrower we'll
know that the task is to go to this
hallway and that we should we should
kind of from there on forward just
always go to this hallway
um and so this is referred to as
posterior sampling
in the sense that you kind of maintain a
kind of posterior distribution over what
you think the task is and then you act
according to that distribution
and so kind of more specifically what
this would look like is
you first learn how to solve and collect
data for all of the training tasks
this will be independent of learning how
to explore
then you'll form a representation of
each task this will be captured by
this variable Z and we'll learn a policy
conditioned on that representation of
the task
um and so for example this is the it
could be like a one hot Vector of like
task one task two task three it could
also be
um a more continuous representation
and then
um once we learn this this
representation of task we can then
learn how to infer a distribution over
the current task
and so it will learn both the kind of a
marginal distribution over the tops
which is p of Z as well as a
distribution q that is trying to
understand the distribution of the task
given the evidence I've seen so far
um and then lastly once we have a policy
conditioned on our test representation
as well as a kind of a distribution over
what we think the task is
then we can do this approach where we
alternate between
sampling from our current distribution
over the task and sampling from the
policy for that task
um and this is what's known as posterior
sampling yeah
yeah so there's a few different ways uh
that you can approach that
um
I guess I can talk concretely about how
we're essentially going to do tasks like
step one and two and in particular
um
I mean in some ways you have to like if
you don't if you aren't able to solve
the training tasks at all then you're
kind of out of luck
um what are the things that's nice is if
you do have a shaped reward for your
tasks then
it will be easier to learn those tasks
whereas oftentimes you might not have a
shaped reward for the exploration
strategy
um
and so
the way that this can work in practice
is um
you could essentially do this with a
kind of a particular form of a black box
architecture where you learn a policy
that is
um still takes the kind of standard form
of conditioning on the current state and
you're training data and outputs in
action
one thing that will make this step
easier is
in this case we're going to use an off
policy approach
to learning the training tasks and so
and we'll maintain a replay buffer a
data set for each of our tasks
and once we do that and we sample D
train from that replay buffer that
buffer will contain some trajectories
that hopefully eventually have actually
figured out or some some directories
that do actually solve the task
and if you condition on that trajectory
in D train then it's easy it's pretty
easy to identify what the task is from
that trajectory
um
and so I guess the
the short answer to your question is
that you do like you do need to be able
to solve the training tests in some
sense and uh once you do solve the
training tasks it isn't too hard to
learn
um learn an architecture like this
foreign
so in terms of these first two steps
we'll learn this uh this policy like
this one thing that's important about
this architecture is that we're going to
be
having this intermediate representation
Z that is kind of uh only takes his
input the training data and as a result
this means that the zi is going to be
capturing information about the task
um and information about the task that's
needed in order to learn the policy in
the critic
yeah
since we had to optimize our adventure
is is
um
maybe a little bit maybe one or two
steps ahead we I guess we I won't
actually be formulating an Evidence
lower bound although you can you can't
actually connect this to a variational
approach
um you can think about the the evidence
as maximizing reward
um
oh I can maybe also get back to that
after we finish kind of explaining the
details of the last two steps
Okay so
um
now we've we've gotten what steps one
and two we have a representation of the
task and we also have a task condition
policy
one thing we do not yet have is this
distribution over the task
um and so we needed essentially impose a
distribution somehow on our task
variable
and the way that we can do this is
actually quite similar to some of the
things that we saw earlier in Bayesian
metal learning where
we instead of having a model
deterministically output Z is going to
Output a mean and a variance over Z
and you'll include determine your
objective that encourages that mean
invariance to be to corresp essentially
the distribution over that variable to
be a gaussian distribution
um and so you can do this again with
kind of a kale Divergence term that
encourages the distribution over your
task to follow a standard gaussian
distribution
and then the complete objective of what
you're going to be doing here is you'll
have a
um you'll have one model that takes his
input
um
D train and outputs kind of amine and a
variance over your task variable so this
will be kind of
Q of Z given D train
and you'll also have another model that
takes his input a particular sample Z
and outputs
um
and gives you a policy for that
particular task
and the objective for learning these two
models is to maximize reward across all
of the tasks
and also to encourage this to actually
represent a distribution rather than
being like a deterministic model
and this will give you
um yeah this will give you essentially
uh exactly what we wanted here which was
addition like kind of a posterior
distribution over the task given the
data set as well as a policy that solves
the task
yeah exactly so the KO Divergence term
is going to incur is going to penalize
it if it's further away from the normal
distribution
one of the things that's really
important about having this term is that
um one thing this model could do is it
could just set like it's going to say it
could say that like oh I just want it to
be deterministic and set the noise to be
zero for example
if it does this then this is a problem
because then when you try to like go and
Sample a task it's just going to give
you a single number rather than a
distribution over what the task might be
um
it's also important to do something like
this because we also want to start with
some prior distribution over our tasks
and by
um by regularizing the distribution to
the zero to this standard gaussian
distribution this prior distribution
will now just be a standard gaussian
distribution
and so when we don't have any evidence
about the training data set we can
sample from the standard gaussian and
that will represent a reasonable
distribution over our tasks
um you can also think of
um
you can also think about the second term
as what's known as a information
bottleneck it's going to essentially
encourage this this task variable to
carry less information about the
training data than it only carry the
information that's needed
um
but you can also just think about it as
essentially just imposing a distribution
over your task variable rather than
having it be a deterministic model
cool and then getting back to the
evidence lower bound question
um
I think that there there is a way to
formulate this as optimizing an Evidence
lower bound it looks a lot like a
variational autoencoder objective that
you as you might notice
um were your Z corresponds to your
latent variable and then you're trying
to maximize reward
so your evidence would be uh it's a
little bit more complicated to actually
derive the the evidence lower bound
because you need to actually think about
reward maximizing reward as actually
maximizing likelihood in a graphical
model and there's actually a lot more
formalism if you want to try to do that
so it gets fairly complicated and it's
kind of beyond the scope of what we'll
cover today
[Music]
yeah so
um you're asking basically does this
assume access to kind of uh
some low dimensional representation of
the task or are you hoping to try to
generalize
God is a distribution of our classes
yeah exactly so
um
by conditioning It On by trying to
infersy this latent variable based on
the training data we are hoping to
generalize potentially
um and this is going to
kind of represent D is going to be a
continuous variable and so it's going to
represent a more continuous distribution
over tasks
um and so in principle this should be
able to generalize to new tasks if you
have if you're
um if your tax distribution is sampled
densely enough if you have enough
training tasks basically
um
and uh yeah and so in this approach kind
of when I was initially explaining this
I was just talking about these kind of
task ideas potentially but by actually
using this this task variable you should
actually be able to generalize whereas
if you only use the task IDs
um you wouldn't be able to generalize to
new tasks
foreign
so to summarize we're learning a a
representation of the task a policy that
conditions conditions on that task and
um
and then doing this form of posterior
sampling in order to
solve the task
um as an example of what this looks like
in an example that's actually fairly
similar to the the mazes is that say
different tasks correspond to these blue
circles and the correct task is this
dark blue circle
then
what it will actually do in practice is
you first sample from Z to um
and then run your policy for that sample
and then once you do that four times
you'll get these four trajectories and
you see that it's kind of sampling from
the distribution of tasks
then once you have this experience you
can then condition your estimate of your
distribution of Z on that experience
and then you'll collect these lighter
purple trajectories that explore in
parts of the space that are not
previously covered from your data
and then you'll notice that one of the
trajectories here actually does go to
the goal and get would get a positive
reward and so once you have this
experience then it can essentially for
the future trajectory shown in Orange
it'll now just uh go directly to the
goal because it's figured out what the
task is
okay
yeah
yeah so you're asking why does
conditioning on your past experience
encourage you to visit tasks that you
haven't visited before
yeah and so the reason why that's the
case is that when you train a model to
infer the task from data if it was given
data that um
that is doing like other tasks then
that's going to help it then then
basically
um
that's going to help it understand what
the task is and
because we're training this encoder both
for the kale Divergence term but also
for the reward
um
when you essentially say say that when
you're optimizing this you're optimizing
for hallway four
then if you condition this on data from
hallway one
um
then
it doesn't know exactly what the task is
but it knows it knows basically that if
it wants to maximize reward it shouldn't
go to hallway one
it basically that the policy won't get
reward for that and so it should it
should uh it should push down those
probabilities
reduce volume
the question is it seems kind of like
cross entropy method
um one thing that's different uh from
cross-entry method is that if you're
getting zero reward for these
cross-entry method
is going to try to take the best ones
and there aren't any good ones in the
sample and so it probably won't do very
well if you it's not going to know that
it should try other things
um the last step is a lot like cross
entropy method where once you do
actually have some good samples it's
going to sample more from that
um but this is actually more powerful
than across entry method because it it
has this ability to reason about like
um about uncertainty over the task even
given negative data
so the question is can you use this for
planning
um
having been able to estimate this
posterior is difficult in general
um and so if you could represent that
posterior during planning then you
should definitely use it
um in practice uh having access to it
you have to learn it in some way and
this is one way to learn it but in
planning we often don't have access to
it
is going to be our prior
and so if we use a kale Divergence to a
standard gaussian distribution then P of
Z will just be the staring Junction
cool
um so now a question for you uh in most
situations might this approach do poorly
yeah so if your [ __ ] here is not very
good then um then this is going to do
very poorly
um what if you have a very good
posterior uh are there scenarios where
you have a great posterior that's very
accurate
um but this still might be a bad
strategy yeah
you have very sparse rewards
um
yes uh although I guess it kind of if
you have a couple tasks and you can like
explore those and sparse Awards will
still be okay
any thoughts on kind of task
distributions or problems where this
would be very inefficient
information
so if you don't gain a lot of
information
from the trajectories
and in particular if you don't get a lot
of information from from which
directories
foreign
yeah so if you have a multimodal
distribution
um it might be
difficult to kind of represent the
multiple modes in him I just like pick
one of them which would do poorly
okay any other thoughts
um any thoughts on kind of this example
and how well posterior sampling would do
here
um
yeah so one thing that it's not going to
do in this example is it's not going to
learn how to read it's just going to
kind of try all the tasks and so this
will be a sub-optimal exploration
strategy because it takes a lot longer
to like try the tasks exhaustively than
to just read and then then figure out
what the task is from there
um and one scenario with which is like
particularly bad is if your hallways are
super long
then like exploring all the hallways is
going to take a lot of time in
comparison to just trying to read the
instructions
and the reason why it doesn't read the
instructions is that
um reading resources isn't actually part
of solving any of the tasks it's just
gonna it just tries to iteratively solve
the tasks it doesn't try to actually
see if there's any information in the
environment that will actually help it
solve help it understand what the task
is that's kind of independent from
actually solving the task
oh
if not information
yeah so if if like the instructions are
actually part of the directory and you
actually see that then it will actually
learn to kind of collapse its posterior
down to the correct task but it's not
going to actually go and see that it's
not going to go out of its way to go see
the instructions
um if that's not part of actually like
getting reward for the task and so
um
yeah it's not going to essentially go
out of its way to find that information
um because it's just sampling from tasks
and sampling from the policy for that
task
and so if for example you have super
um your goals are really far away and
this kind of these instructions are
assigned on the wall tells you uh
exactly what to do then it's not going
to actually go seek out that information
yeah
objection doesn't have to learn how to
read or does it already know how to read
um
I guess there are different variants of
the problem you could have one where it
like if it's like goes here it like it's
told directly like one two three four
five or something where it goes here and
it gets an image and it has to learn how
to read the text and solve a math
problem and figure out what the number
is
um in both cases it's not it's in both
those cases it's not going to actually
go here
um it's going posterior sampling
approaches we'll just try to try to
sample tasks and solve tasks
and so the reason why I bring this up is
that
um this approach is a lot better than
end-to-end optimization in that it's a
lot easier
to ultimately figure out how to solve
the tasks
the downside is that it may end up on
stride with exploration strategies that
are very sub-optimal so in some cases
the strategy will be fine in other cases
um
it uh it might be arbitrarily bad like
if the hallways are infinitely long for
example
um another example of something that
would be better than this approach right
here is instead of like kind of going to
each of those if it first went here and
then kind of walked around the circle
then they could actually figure out what
the task is in just a single episode
rather than requiring a lot of episodes
to explore
and that's even without a sign
okay
so this was our first kind of
alternative approach to an end-to-end
optimization
and this is not end to end because we
are not learning our exploration
strategy end to end we're actually using
this different strategy for exploring
and then we're learning how to solve the
task uh based on our uh on information
we inferred from that exploration
um one second alternative approach that
I'll talk about is um
to
instead of uh instead of doing any sort
of posterior sampling we're going to try
to explore in a way that tells us
information about the Dynamics and the
reward
and the way that we can do this is if we
learn a Dynamics model and a reward
function
for all of the tasks conditioned on our
training data
then what we could do is we could try to
train an exploration strategy such that
this model is accurate
um and so
um once we have this model we can then
kind of
train an exploration policy that gets
high reward if this model has low error
and so what an approach like this would
look like is uh for each task you
collect some data with your current
exploration policy
then you also collect data with the
execution policy a separate policy that
tries to solve the task
based on their collected data
and then train your exploration policy
with respect to the reward of kind of
the negative error of your Dynamics
model
and then train your
um
train your execution policy with respect
to the the goal of solving the tasks
um and so note here the exploration
policy and the execution policy have
different reward functions they're
optimizing for different things
um
and uh and this is essentially this this
exploration policy is going to try to
find things that allow it to predict the
reward in the Dynamics
um and so in this example right here uh
the Dynamics are all the same across all
of the tasks
um I guess actually no that's that's not
quite right so
um but then it was actually a little bit
different so the Dynamics are different
here at the instructions
because if you kind of move on to the
instructions you're going to see
something different for different tasks
because the instructions are different
for different tasks and then you also
have different Rewards
and so what this approach is going to do
is it's going to try to learn a model of
the Dynamics and the reward and then
seek out parts of the state space that
allow it to differentiate different
tasks
um and so then what it's going to do in
this case is uh
the exploration policy once you learn a
model Based on data the exploration
policy will actually be encouraged to
seek out this this state because
um that will help it actually uh
differentiate what the reward is going
to be
um
yeah and so if you also look at the
example that we looked at before
where we have these different goals then
it will actually learn a policy that
looks like this
where it's essentially trying to
learn how to kind of estimate the reward
of the task and a good way to explore to
figure out what the reward is is to
actually go kind of around the circle
rather than uh kind of sampling from the
posterior
cool
um any questions on how this works
foreign
yeah so this example is different than
this one um they're they're related but
in this case like if you can't actually
go around the circle because the
Dynamics don't let you do that then
um
then you then you can't take this
approach
um so the examples are are a little bit
different here
um
and so to summarize what's happening
here we're going to learn
um to predict the Dynamics and the
reward given the state action and our
experience this is just trained with
like mean squirter or something like
that
then we'll learn
um an exploration policy that gets kind
of
um it gets high reward if the data that
it collected helps this model
predictable
so it's uh
uh good if
f is able to accurately predict the
Dynamics on the reward it also gets kind
of negative reward if it's inaccurate
and then you'll also train
um this is kind of just this can be done
completely separately from actually
solving the tasks
and then this execution policy is can
many ways just be trained after the fact
in order to try to actually
um
solve the tasks given the training data
and this is just going to be trying to
uh
maximize
expected reward of this policy
and so this is essentially decoupling
exploration from execution because you
can first just train this model and
explore so that this model is accurate
and then separately use your
use your experience to actually figure
out how to solve the tasks
yeah great question so um the
exploration reward
um
it's essentially set to be the negative
error of this model and the intuition is
that
um if this model is accurate that means
that you've been able to distinguish
information about the task you've been
able to predict the Dynamics or the
reward for that task
and so
this is going to be rewarded in cases
where you've learned information that
helps it distinguish different tasks and
you're going to get a negative reward if
this model is um is inaccurate if it's
not able to predict the Dynamics and the
reward for the current task
support
oh great question
um so
yeah so essentially this reward is
um I'll write it out right here so
uh
not that
so you're gonna sample
your training data from your exploration
policy
and then
the reward is going to be evaluated on
this training data so the reward for
exploration will be
um
kind of for the state action pairs in
this collected experience
what is the negative
error which is
F of s
a minus
um
R and S Prime
so this is the kind of
the full equation for the reward yeah
foreign
so
um one thing that one issue that might
come up is if you
um
right great so if you only evaluate this
on on the support set then it might just
like just stay in place
um and not actually be able to
uh which is actually bad
um
the
um and so
yeah that's interesting I actually
I can't remember actually how they dealt
with that problem um I'm guessing that
actually it's probably a mix of D train
and um
sorry yes okay so
this model is conditioned on
your training experience and so you want
um right so you want your model to be
able to predict well based on your
training experience and then this
expectation I think is actually going to
be
um with respect to states that are
sampled from
um
from a policy that's solving the task or
something that's actually more broad
than just the training experience yeah
that's a great correction
um
so I'll just name that Di
but it's very important that these these
are the same thing because this is
actually what the model is using to make
predictions
or Trinidad is called produced in policy
because that is
so basically I'm thinking okay I'm
probably introduced another exploration
bring water space that cannot surprise
I think that's a
impactful one is
um so yeah one downside to this is that
you do have to train a Dynamics model uh
and the training this might be
expensive you're suggesting that instead
of trying to minimize model air you'll
try to learn things that are surprising
to the model that it can't model
accurately
um
I'm
I think that that's a reasonable
approach that is actually people have
done that in like standard reinforcement
learning
um I'm not sure if that would
necessarily learn exploration strategies
that are targeted for particular tasks
and one thing that's nice about this
objective is it is going to try to
discover the things that are different
among different tasks and use that to
solve the task and that's a good
strategy because if you learn about
everything that's interesting there
might be like a lot of things that are
interesting and surprising
but aren't relevant to the task
and essentially what we want to do when
learning exploration strategies is to
find things that
help us figure out what the task is and
ignore things that are irrelevant to the
task
um
so that said one thing that is
um that is potentially bad about this
approach is if there are parts of the
Dynamics that are different across tasks
but irrelevant to solving the task then
it will actually
it will actually try to seek those out
um
and so yeah essentially if there are uh
a lot of task irrelevant distractors
also if you're in a very complex
high-dimensional State space where
learning a model is difficult
um this sort of approach will be less
satisfying
cool um so overall these approaches are
generally a lot easier to optimize than
the end-to-end optimization
um because the exploration strategy is
like the objective for the exploration
strategy is more decoupled from the uh
from actually learning to solve the task
they're not optimizing the same
objective
a lot of them are based on principled
strategies for exploration
but the downside is that these
approaches can be arbitrarily
sub-optimal so for example in posterior
sampling we saw that it might it won't
like learn how to read instructions
likewise for this for the second
approach if there are aspects of the
Dynamics that are different across tasks
that are very interesting but are
completely irrelevant to solving the
task like maybe there are kind of I
don't know lots of paintings on the wall
that vary across different tasks then
this approach is going to try to explore
all of those details which
will not be very useful and will be very
they might spend a lot of time doing
that rather than actually learning to
differentiate the things that are
relevant for solving the task
cool
um and so
what I'd like to uh get to now is an
approach that actually tries to decouple
these two things without sacrificing
optimality
and it turns out this is actually it is
actually possible to essentially get the
best of both worlds
um where
we're able to explore
um in a way that is only relevant to the
task
and also
um and also do so in a way that's very
efficient
without having this coupling problem
cool so um the last solution that we
talked about was to try to predict the
Dynamics and explore in a way that
allows you to better predict the
Dynamics
but do we really have to learn a full
Dynamics model and a full reward model
the idea that we're going to look at
here uh the or the almost final idea is
to label each of your training tasks
with a unique identifier
this could just be a one-hot identifier
like you just enumerate all of your
training tasks
and then you're instead of trying to
predict the Dynamics and the reward
you're going to try to predict this
identifier
and so
what this will look like in this example
is
um
instead of predicting Dynamics and
reward we're just going to try to
predict what the task identifier is
and
this model will be accurate essentially
when it finds things that are different
among the tasks
and so if the instructions are something
that's different in the different
environments then this will encourage
the exploration model to
find the thing that helps it
differentiate between the tasks very
quickly
and so
um
that's kind of what the what the
exploration strategy will look like and
so concretely
um
we're going to train this task
identification model
um I guess I named it Q
and also train exploration policy that
tries to explore if Q is accurate
and so it's the exploration policy is
trained such that when you sample data
from your exploration policy you're able
to accurately predict the task
and then we'll separately uh train an
execution policy that is just
conditioned on the task identifier
and this last part should be really easy
because
um this just amounts to solving the task
independent of figuring out how to
explore for those tasks and so this is
completely decoupled
and then once you do this then that meta
test time you can explore by
collecting data from your exploration
policy then infer what you think the
task ID is
and then condition your execution policy
on this task identifier
and so one of the things that's really
nice about this is now you no longer
have to model the Dynamics and the
rewards
and it should actually encourage it to
find things that are different about
different environments
and so going back to our objective right
here
this will now be something that's trying
to predict uh
just the task identifier from your
training data and this is going to be
uh
be compared to the true task identifier
and then the reward for your exploration
policy will be how well it's able to
predict the task of identifier
and then so we have these three models
we have something that takes as input
um
we have our exportion policy which then
outputs your training data we also have
a model that takes
training data and predicts mu and then
lastly a model that takes mu and
predicts
um
or solves the task from there
okay now one I guess
can anyone spot any downsides with this
approach
very close
yeah so if your task identifiers if
Junior task identifiers are like very
close in value but in reality they're
very different then this is a problem
um if you use a one-hod identifier this
will be better and then instead of using
mean squared error you could do like
cross entropy loss um and that will
that will resolve that issue
um
any other thoughts
yeah so this is essentially the
um the the downside which is that if you
give it a new task identifier if you
have like a new task for example
um
then it's not gonna be able to like if
this is like your one hot Vector is for
all of your training tasks then it's
gonna it's not gonna know how to predict
like a one-hot identifier for the new
task
um and so it won't generalize well to
new tasks
because you're just using especially if
you're using one hot identifiers
um
yeah great question so the question is
um it seems like maybe we still need
trajectories that like go read and then
solve the task and maybe this doesn't
solve the problem
um
the reason why this can solve the
problem is that for different tasks
there are going to be the instructions
are going to look different
and what this exploration policy is
going to try to do is it's going to try
to
be able to discern the task identity
from its interactions and because the
instructions look different for
different tasks it can discern what task
it's in by just walking to the
instructions and stopping there
yeah so the question is um without
reward feedback how does it know which
task list corresponds to
um
by enumerating your task identifiers
um this reward doesn't depend on the
task reward in any way
it just is looking at whether you're
able to predict the task that you're
currently in the environment that you're
in
and so it'll essentially get this
exploration policy will get a reward
just for being able to predict a task
identifier completely separate for
actually being able to solve the task
from that identifier
yeah
so this is going to assume that you have
task identifiers that you've been able
to enumerate all of your training tasks
and you know which training task you're
currently exploring in yeah
yeah so if you use a non-one hot task
identifier is this better
um
it is better if you can
um on in the next couple slides we'll
talk about approach that will still work
even when you have one hot task
identifiers but it definitely gets a lot
better if you have more informative task
identifiers
so how do you get these task identifiers
in practice
um it kind of depends on the domain but
if for example we're in the kitchen
kitchen example where the goal is to
like cook a meal in different kitchens
and you need to find ingredients in
different kitchens then basically
whenever you collect experience in a
kitchen you tell it like you're in
kitchen one and if you're in a different
kitchen you say you're in kitchen two or
a different kitchen you're in kitchen
three and you just need to make sure
that your you are consistent saying like
you're in kitchen three when you're
actually in kitchen three
oh sorry I think I misunderstood your
question you're asking how do you get
non-one hot and in the first
um yeah so getting on one hot
identifiers is harder
um
you would need to say you need to be
able to like give it features that
distinguish the kitchens for example
um that identify like
worthy like what what cabinet are the
ingredients in and what is like
um what are like what's other
information about the environment yeah
um yes and so that's that's what we'll
do on the next slide is essentially try
to learn a better task identifier that
isn't one hot
um from the one hot task identifier yeah
[Music]
yeah maybe I'll just explain oh maybe
I'll kind of talk about how we how we
solve this so
essentially what we're going to do is
we're still going to assume that we have
these one hot identifiers and we're
going to try to learn a representation
we're basically going to introduce
a
an additional model that goes from one
Hut identifier to our task
representation
and so
I'm
gonna
erase this stuff
so we're going to have
um
foreign model that goes from our task
identifier or one hot task and
identifier to a better task
representation
we're also going to have a model that
goes from this task representation
to actually solving the task
so this is our execution policy
and then
we're also going to have our
exploration policy and this is going to
spit out some
some data that it explored with
and then we'll have one final model that
can try to predict
the task from this training data and
instead of predicting the one hot is
just going to try to predict our Z
um
so this will essentially have this is
like four different models
um
this is we'll refer to as Q because it's
trying to infer the task from the data
this is just our execution policy this
is our exploration policy and then
um this model right here will call
capital f
um
if we can learn these four things
then what we can do
at metatest time is we will then
um
we'll take our exploration policies
which will give us data
we'll predict Z
from
that data and then we'll plug this into
are
execution policy
and so by the test time we're going to
kind of throw away this encoder part
this will just be used during meta
training to learn a better task
representation and once we have that
we'll then be able to explore collect a
training data set get a good task
representation and pass that to our
execution policy
um so this is kind of a sketch of how
things are going to work
and so in particular there's two aspects
of meta training
the first part will be learning this
first model right here which is going to
both learn how to solve the tasks
conditioned on the task ID
and also learn a good representation of
the task in the process
and so
this will essentially just train a
policy condition on one Hots we're going
to bottleneck the representation on this
intermediate variable Z
the mdp identifier could be a big one
hot Vector it could also be
some other descriptive information about
the environment
and then
um this is just doing standard kind of
one hot conditioned reinforcement
learning
and then for the second stage we're
going to learn how to explore by trying
to recover and be able to predict RZ
um our task representation
and so this will be trying to train an
exploration policy that collects data
that allows you to predict what the task
variable is
um
cool and so in this first step this like
I mentioned this is basically just going
to be
doing trying to maximize the task reward
with respect to your execution policy
we're also going to
impose a distribution on Z like we did
before
this is just going to encourage it to
throw information and throw out
information in the one hot identifier
and learn a representation that's more
compressed
and then for the Second Step
um
we need to train our our exploration
policy in order to predict the task
representation
[Music]
um
and uh
while you can you can do these
separately you can also just train them
all at once as well in practice it will
probably learn the first step before it
learns the second step
yeah so what this could just learn in
identity mapping and by adding the kale
Divergence and adding noise we're going
to encourage it to not learn the
identity mapping and try to compress
that representation
cool so this is also a decoupled
approach and that we're training the
execution policy and the exploration
policy with different objectives and
we're first gonna we can first train the
execution policy and then train the
exploration policy
um one more detail in terms of training
this exploration policy is you could use
a reward similar to the reward that we
talked about before
which would be to essentially
be able
um
simply try to be able to predict Z
uh from your training experience
one detail is that you could do this at
the very end of the episode but it would
be nice if our exploration our
exploration policy got rewards at every
single time step
and so what you can do is you can
actually give it this reward based on
the all the data that's collected so far
and do that at every single time step
now the downside to that is if you do it
if you do this for the data collected so
far then you're going to start double
counting because if it had great
um it explored well like at time step
one but then did like random stuff after
that then you're still going to be
giving a positive reward for that
and so what we'll do in practice is
we're going to
um
we're going to actually try to measure
this per step Information Gain about Z
uh and the way that we can do this is
have the reward correspond to the
prediction error
um comparing the prediction error up
until the current time step and the
prediction error up until the previous
time step
and this is going to get essentially
higher reward if it is able to
effectively lower the prediction error
from the previous time step to the
current time step
and this will essentially give it a more
dense reward to say at this current time
step did you actually help me gain
information about what the task variable
is
um
the question was is this like adding a
baseline
um
it's not quite like adding a baseline
because it's not a constant that you're
adding
um
so it is
um it's essentially just trying to
prevent double Counting
and it's just looking at it you can't
actually formalize it as uh Information
Gain
okay
um so this last approach is referred to
as uh dream through a somewhat
um mangled acronym
[Music]
um
in terms of trying to get the best of
both worlds from this approach we'd love
to get both kind of
um
both a good exploration strategy as well
as efficiency from learning we're
running low on time so I'll go through
this pretty quickly but essentially you
can show that the dream objective is
consistent with end-to-end optimization
and what I mean by this is that kind of
in the limit like as your
um as you're meta trading data kind of
goes to Infinity then
the expected reward of uh
dream is going to be uh essentially
equal to the expected reward of the
end-to-end approach
so essentially as you get more and more
Mediterranean data
the solutions will be the same you'll
get the optimal solution in both cases
um this is under somewhat mild
assumptions
um
and so yeah essentially means in
principle you can recover the optimal
strategy
you can also do some theoretical
analysis on efficiency as well uh doing
analysis on efficiency is difficult
in general and so if you look at a more
bandit-like setting
um
I think I don't have time to explain the
setup but essentially you can show that
the sample efficiency of an end-to-end
approach in Orange
is very terrible as you make the
exploration more difficult whereas the
um the sample complexity of a dreamlike
approach is much nicer as the
exploration becomes more difficult
um the dashed lines are showing the
theoretical results and the solid lines
are showing the empirical results
and so you see that the theory does seem
to be indicative although it's actually
in practice it seems to be an even
bigger difference
cool um so to summarize uh the
end-to-end approaches will in principle
lead to the optimal strategy in practice
it's a pretty challenging optimization
the alternative strategies are a lot
easier to optimize and many of them are
fairly principled
but they can also be sub-optimal by an
arbitrarily large amount
and the decoupled approach that we saw
last will lead to the optimal strategy
in principle it's also easy to optimize
so we really get the best of both worlds
it does have this requirement of being
able to kind of assign a one-hot
identifier to all of your tasks in
practice this is fairly mild but it is
it's one thing that is using in order to
get the best of both worlds
um
you can also empirically compare these
different approaches
um in this example different tasks
correspond to going to different objects
and you need the agent starts behind the
wall and it needs to the optimal thing
is to go around the wall to read the
sign to figure out the color of the
correct object and then go to the
correct object
um all of it's from Pixel observations
and sparse rewards so it's a pretty
challenging problem
and if we look at the average return as
a function of meta training experience
we see that the end-to-end approach is
shown in yellow green and red
all do very poorly because it's really
hard to learn exploration and ex
execution together
um we see that using something like
posterior sampling is able to do better
um
then these approaches but it cannot
learn the optimal exploration strategy
because it's going to try to like go to
objects and get Negative rewards when
you go to the wrong object
and then lastly the last approach that
we talked about uh
can efficiently learn a good approach
and it also starts to approach the
um the optimal reward for the task
and you can actually look at what the
behavior it does and you can see this is
the exploration episode and it learns to
go around the wall and then look at the
sign
and the execution policy uses this
um next version Episode infers what the
task is and then goes to
um it goes to the right object
cool
um so that was uh the main plan for
today a quick roadmap for the remaining
lectures
um next week we'll be talking about
um
offline multitaskerl and hierarchical
Earl in the following week we'll have
some really awesome guest lectures and
the week after that we'll be talking
about lifelong learning and Frontiers
um you can essentially think of next
week as the final reinforcement learning
topics the following week as some
lectures on multitask NLP and learned
optimizers and then the last week about
learning tasks sequentially and then
some open challenges in the field
um
the next week and the last week are
lectures that will be taught by
um Carl and the week in between our
guest lectures and so this is my last
lecture for the course I just want to
thank everyone for being kind of an
engaging student group and yeah I really
enjoyed teaching everyone
[Applause]